all right today walker furniture  continues it's home for the holidays  event  it's now the company's 27th year one  recipient this year is  tiffany penny she has two teens and  works at a local hospital  her family has been displaced twice over  the past four years earlier this year  they lost  all of their belongings in a house fire  they just told told me about this last  week i'd had  no idea i had no idea that this was  going on  but i like we are so appreciative like  we needed it  so bad and we just want to say thank you  congrats to you tiffany because of  safety protocols some of this year's  deliveries will have to wait  until after the new year but it's such a  fantastic program